congratulations there's so much to
celebrate let's start with the fact that
I mean you really did go from being
bullied by the entire house to becoming
America's favorite player to the winner
of Big Brother how does it feel to
really have the greatest Redemption
story in Big Brother history wow it's
again it just blows my mind because I
was just someone who was a very very
passive casual enjoyer I can't even
really say fan of the show I started
watching last season that's what brought
me in and started going back to watch
other Seasons so to know that that I
could make a mark on this franchise in
this way is unbelievable Kyle's vote
goes to
congratulations Taylor
you are the winner of Big Brother
asked you that I have been this iconic
type of person in the franchise because
you look at other people like a I got a
Janelle or a evil dick or like these
people who just make these massive marks
and moments on the game and to come in
kind of picked up off the sidewalk and
do the same thing it just it doesn't
feel real well it's like first of all
your last remarks to the uh jury where
like I mean I literally was like yes I
have overcome so much in this game and
I've come to understand that I am not a
shield I am a sword I am not a victim I
am a Victor and if there is one word
that is going to describe the entire
season it is resiliency it was just so
poetic and I mean they voted for
progress and on that note I mean you are
the first black woman to ever win a
normal season of Big Brother first of
all how does that feel again those words
don't feel real but also I think it's a
testament to the mechanics of the game
over 24 seasons you know we have black
women who have played this game over and
over and they have been bullied many
times and they have been ostracized in
other ways and evicted very early or
with the case of Danielle uh season
three got to the very end and didn't
take the win because the jury had a
different color of her so
whew not to get all emotional because my
eyeliner needs to say where it is that's
a good deal yeah it's a big deal it is
it's a very very big deal and I think
that
it's not just that I was a black woman
who was a cop Beast it's not that I was
a black woman who was well alike because
I was not well liked in this house it's
that I was a black woman who took on a
lot of the pain and burden and
stereotypes that have happened over and
over and over again in the show and I
still made it to the end I refused to
give up on myself I refuse to give up on
the mission and I took the win so now I
hope it's giving space for black women
in the rest of this game to just play
their own game
I mean you really are the you know I
feel like you're the epitome of
resilience like you mentioned tonight
and I don't know if you know this but 20
years ago to the day Danielle Reyes
placed second in season three so she was
the first black woman to be in the top
two and you're the first black woman to
win I mean 20 years later and I I again
that's something I never would have it's
just it truly is poetic it's what I want
and it is poetic now if I were you going
through what you went through in this
house I'd be like I'm out I didn't sign
up for this but you didn't what did you
say
it was tempting I would think uh there
were there were a handful of moments it
was very tempting to say there's a whole
summer Beyonce released new album for
that like Deuces them out but I think
what I just it was so important for me
to defend my character because I did not
want to leave this house and have to
wait two and a half months to say I told
you so I want this Congeniality I'm a
nice person no you only come to
understand that you are wrong about your
assumptions of people by learning from
them and understanding who they are as
people comfortable I had to stick it out
and do it and you proved that this
really it like the social game is so
crucial in this you know and you really
did get to know everybody on a human
level and relate to them um and you got
to know Monty pretty well uh you and
Monty began a little show man bear
Taylor a couple weeks ago no seriously
is there something you want to pursue is
that something you want to pursue in the
real world oh my God okay I hope he
doesn't kill me for this I think that
conversation we had where I was I don't
know if that's what the woman I was in
the tub and we kind of had a conflict
there I think healthy communication is a
Hallmark of a strong relationship I
think the uh context of the headphones
that he was bringing to me and talking
about how he felt disrespected I just I
was like
a little asinine to me so that's
something that's going to rub somebody's
ego the wrong way I don't know if
there's a relationship to pursue there
okay so what about Joseph because he did
say he wanted to pursue something with
you after I mean he now knows that you
know you and Monty had a moment but
where does your heart lie my heart wow
oh my God these big things look
unapologetically relentlessly and
there's clearly one person who has done
that more so than the other so depending
on how he feels about how things put out
with Monty because I want to be
respectful everybody's emotions but I
would I wouldn't mind seeing a date I
won't be mad about a date we'll take it
real quick did you hear which pop star
is headlining Super Bowl
I know like I'm begging Rihanna I'm what
is it Rihanna Navy like get me to the
Super Bowl maybe I'll bring Monty I'll
bring him it's fine we'll hang out he
brought me to final two I'll bring the
Super Bowl I think there you go
[Music]